momento de hablar de economía en directo
América pero yo le doy la bienvenida a
mi compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge qué tal
Muy bien Andrés y vos Bien también Jorge
iniciamos con el dato de inflación de
Estados Unidos que movió los mercados
bursátiles bueno sin duda alguna fue un
muy buen dato con el 7,7% anual la
inflación de octubre fue la más lenta
desde enero justo antes del inicio de la
guerra de Rusia en Ucrania que
desencadenó en un aumento mundial de los
precios de las materias primas la
inflación fue bajo un 0,4% respecto a
septiembre y excluyendo los volátiles
precios de los alimentos y la energía la
inflación subyacente aumentó un 6,3% en
los últimos 12 meses y un 0,3 desde
septiembre toda la cifra fueron
inferiores a las esperadas por los
economistas con una desaceleración en
todas las categorías el informe sugiere
que está alza de precios en Estados
Unidos comienza Ya ahora a ceder ahora
se espera también que el dato de la
ayuda de la reserva Federal de Estados
Unidos para dar seguridad a moderar sus
agresivas su vida de los tipos de la
reserva Federal ha aumentado su tipo de
interés de referencia seis veces en
incrementos considerables este año lo
que aumenta Los costos de los préstamos
por ejemplo para las compras de
viviendas automóviles y otros artículos
de Gran valor el temor de la mayoría de
los economistas Es que esto haga que la
mayor Economía del mundo pueda incluir
entrar en una recesión económica Jorge
de los indicadores empezamos en Wall
Street que generó fuerte subidas donde
el dow Jones de industriales ganó un
3,70% y vivió su mejor día en más de dos
años Mientras que el Tecnológico nasdaq
se disparó un 7,35% en Europa las
acciones alcanzaron un máximo de 11
semanas luego del dato de inflación que
reforzó las esperanzas de los
inversionistas de que la reserva Federal
de ese país sea menos agresiva en las
subidas de los tipos de interés en el
futuro y en América Latina no fue un
buen día especialmente en Brasil donde
los inversores se impacientaron por el
deseo del intelecto Lula da Silva de
impulsar el gasto social sin establecer
reglas Fiscales a largo plazo ni nombrar
a sus principales responsables de la
política económica y es que los
inversores también se alejaron del dólar
esto porque una menor inflación refuerza
la teoría de que la reserva Federal de
Estados Unidos reduzca su agresiva
política monetaria para frenar la
inflación y aumente el apetito por los
activos de riesgo el dólar se ha
fortalecido en máximos de dos décadas en
los últimos meses esto por precisamente
por la seguridad de los tipos de interés
la volatilidad de los mercados y también
cierta incertidumbre geopolítica en la
jornada de hoy la moneda estadounidense
perdía hasta un 3,1% frente al yen
japonés su mayor caída en un día desde
junio del 2016 frente al Euro perdía un
1,5% su mayor caída desde el 4 de
noviembre ahora crece el temor de un
retroceso agresivo del dólar pero esto
es una buena noticia para los mercados
emergentes el dólar dio un respiro al
peso colombiano y el peso mexicano fue
la segunda moneda más apreciada de las
Divisas emergentes porque vamos con
noticias de Venezuela que donde la
pobreza extrema bajó 14,7 puntos
respecto a 2021 bueno Andrés según nos
investigadores esto se da por la
recuperación económica de ese país
Aunque incluso aumentó de cierta forma
la desigualdad el 53,3% de los
venezolanos vive por debajo del umbral
de la pobreza extrema si esta es medida
por ingresos según la encuesta sobre
condiciones de vida elaborada por la
Universidad Católica Andrés Bello la
encuesta también muestra que el 81,5% de
la población porcentaje que También
incluye a los anteriores se encuentra
por debajo del umbral de la pobreza lo
que también representa una reducción del
8,5 puntos porcentuales en comparación
con 2021 el estudio determinó que los
programas sociales en Venezuela han
quedado reducido a dos las
transferencias monetarias y la entrega
de alimentos a través de cajas de los
comités locales de abastecimiento y
producción Jorge Cerramos el Reino Unido
se congeló activos rusos por un valor de
21 mil millones de euros bueno Reino
Unido ha sancionado ya a más de 1.200
personas a 120 entidades y a congelado
los activos de 19 bancos rusos según la
oficina de implementación de sanciones
financieras el volumen de esas sanciones
este 6.855 millones de euros superior al
de cualquier otro régimen sancionador
que aplique este país con este Reino
Unido espera continuar golpeando al
gobierno ruso a nivel financiero por su
invasión a Ucrania se prevé que el
producto interno bruto ruso disminuye
hasta un 6,2% en 2022 frente a los
pronósticos previos a la invasión y un
2,3% más en 2023 Jorge Hurtado con la
información económica Gracias seguimos
con más en directo América
[Música]